so you generally have three sorts of
people you've got tourists
you've got journalists and you've got
problem solvers the tourists just there
for the ride and the journalists report
problems this is bad this is bad what
you really want to have is problem
solvers and that's what entrepreneurs
you
in life I've tried many filled
businesses many field ventures and
during those period of a people called
me failure it found that my first up I'm
22 the company failed I try again to
company fail thankfully as you know we
are learning you know I think the best
teacher and when you're not feeling you
means you're not trying you're not
growing you're not learning at all
Sophia is something that I personally
embrace and I smile when I feel because
I want to overcome it I don't have any
problem with somebody sincerely
believing that they have the right
answer and turning out to have had the
wrong answer in that sense I'm a strong
believer in accepting well intentioned
failure that that what what makes it
well intentioned was that you were
trying to get to the right answer
I got virtually everything wrong so I
lent you know my lesson the hard way we
understood there's some key problems
that we have that we didn't have a clue
hardened soul we were growing at a
tremendous pace and we didn't know which
road we needed to take and gets him to
know about stuff of Sikkim was a miracle
we had done seven years of running a
business we'd survived three near
bankruptcy and you were sort of feeling
like you know I'm learnt all there is to
know no
so what possibly could could see it
offer me and yet the experience was
nothing like what I thought it would be
it was phenomenal you're running your
business day-to-day and you're seeing it
like this right you're looking at all
the challenges the problems weaknesses
district you know the competition the
regulatory the government
that and then you have seed and Stanford
C teaches you to think like like that
[Music]
the seed transformation program is a
program targeted at the founders and
leaders of small and medium-sized
businesses in developing economies seat
for me is actually the number one game
changer it's like going to business
school really but it's I think it's even
better if you have a process tools
methodology the seed transformation
program as that program that actually
helps you to plan your business so that
it can outlive you it came in a right
time to help think through some of the
challenges things like how to deal with
corruption things like how to motivate
your staff with the same resources we're
about five times more efficient than we
were with in these times of Enoch I've
encountered see my business has grown
more than 50 percents we've just opened
our tenth store from six we've grown to
ten we're gonna open another two in the
next couple of months and maybe another
two before the end of the year we've
more than doubled our revenues the last
one year we have grown 300%
we've gone from thirty people to eighty
we just closed with acumen fund so to be
now written about to be new other
countries I think what we've seen so far
is it seems to work they are some of the
most energetic they are some of the most
committed they are some of the most
entrepreneurial and insightful leaders
that I have ever interacted with I think
that's what the seed program gives you
that this courage to see clearly where
you're going and so you don't stop
working because that you know the
journey has just begun first my ambition
was trust me me my family but now it's
not is difference is my country is my
region is
is Africa is the Lord I think successful
is about impact it doesn't matter what
you've accomplished personally he are
not yet seeing the correlation across
the continent you'd like to see I only
be successful why we've been able to get
a platform that those who are yet to be
born when they are giving birth to the
moment they land on this path yeah they
have access with very basic things in my
part of the world
[Music]
you